out of all the cast from the DC shows
that you haven't worked with who would
you like to work with most Supergirl
yeah I think it'd be fun to see all the
female superheroes on all four of the
shows just team up and like what but I
think that would be a good episode I
also want to get between the Prison
Break brothers come on guys mine's PG I
think that our show is like an onion and
every season you open a whole new layer
to the onion and it's not like we can't
be deep dark and depressing because
let's face it we can be the season
finale was a beautiful proof of that but
I think that you know through the
evolution of our characters and some of
them going through personal growth as
well as emotional growth like how Oliver
has Felicity and is now settled down I
think there's just that natural
evolution of it things becoming a little
lighter until they're not anymore which
is a huge possibility you know things
things happen on arrow that aren't
necessarily good for the characters I
also think it's really cool because one
of the cool things about the Green Arrow
versus a lot of the other superheroes
out there is that he doesn't have any
supernatural powers so the cool thing
about having the metahumans get involved
which does turn it in
a little bit more like supernatural like
fantastic kind of show is that the green
era he basically outsmarts them all in
the comics so it's really fun to see him
finally get to do that and be like you
have superpowers I don't how do I
outsmart you so I think that's a really
cool element that gets introduced agreed
you know I don't think this show is
going anywhere anytime
I can't necessarily confirm or deny that
but I can say from your guys's response
as well as the network's response to our
show and the creation of all the others
that are you know interlocked into each
other it's it's kind of gonna be a
never-ending cycle for a little while I
don't think anything's gonna happen
anytime soon like that season for the
team broke up and disbanded what do you
think it's gonna be the next big bad and
how do you think the team is gonna get
back together well I actually just heard
a rumor or maybe a true comment about
who our next big bad was and it's
actually the first time I've heard it
today was that the character may or may
not be named James James James so
whoever's in the crowd named James James
come out and fight me bro he'll break me
like a twig but for season 5 I think you
know the team in its and its own right
has gone through these moments where you
know Oliver left and we were left to
kind of fend for ourselves and figure
out our own place in the team but I
think that now that we're at this moment
where we're all trying to figure out our
own place in ourselves and our own
lives because everything kind of got a
little disbanded since damian darhk--
and you know it's not like we're not
gonna be back together I think that
you're gonna see a reuniting front
moment probably sooner than you think as
well as each of us you know we're just
maxing and relaxing on a cool island
right now I need some R&R how much have
I learned and trained for the archery
right before I got to actually pick up
the bow I think I had a good spouse they
actually gave me warning guys which is
really rare in our show uh it gave me
good like six months warning and they
set up a whole bunch of our chi classes
with our main archery coach Patricia and
I nailed my first bullseye first-day
seventh try boom I'm pretty good at
shooting a bow and arrow I can take
pride and actually saying that so yeah
you know that that skills actually a
real skill now we're just cool to be
able to say yes who wants to be any pig
got an apple and who wants to wear it on
their head um I actually did all of my
training with the bow and arrow on
Spartacus so yeah she knows what she's
doing far before I did so yeah yeah I'm
Sparty they were really cool though
because on arrow you're not actually
allowed to shoot an arrow because it's
compound bow and it will murder somebody
and they care about those things uh but
on Spartacus he didn't care and I
actually got $5.00 any time I ever hit
the camera or a cameraman oh yeah play
that game just out of curiosity how much
money did you make well in one day I
made $10 which was pretty good because I
wasn't supposed to be hitting them so
that meant I was like aiming that way
and they were there and I was like
whoops
but I never got my money well I think
the scene that caity lotz and I want to
do at some point in the future and I
know the writers have talked about it is
the scene where she and I first meet on
the shores but she washes up on the
shores of non depart bot and kind of how
I took her in how she trained
introducing her to my father for the
first time how we fell in love and that
entire backstory so I know we're loving
we'd like we would love to have that
happen um but I think next season if if
you know my character comes back and I
don't know one way or another if she is
but I think it'd be really cool to
interact more with the other women of
arrow as well with speedy and Thea and
you know Alyssa Felicity felicity so I
think it'd be fun to have some really
strong female scenes just well one of
the things we keep talking about is how
great our show is for the female
characters yeah the writers have done
such a great job
I mean her character is a prime example
going from a little schoolgirl to like
this powerhouse of a woman who can hold
her own whereas before she was this you
know little girl who was a victim and
couldn't really take care of herself so
to see that development and growth in
same thing with Katie Cassidy with the
Black Canary to go from a lawyer who had
all these issues to going to the Black
Canary who was fighting and defending
her city and fighting for freedom and
justice and everything the writers do a
great job on that show so I I really
think it'd be fun to work with Willa and
Emily so I think that'd be cool yeah
come hang out girl girl you
yeah um definitely without fail the
hardest scene to film this season was
our last scene with Katie Cassidy
especially everything in the hospital
all of that stuff all those here is
everything that was emotional about that
scene was 110 percent real and it always
is when when it comes to us losing one
of our limbs I mean that's what that's
what it feels like and coming back to
work after that was not easy either but
we love her and she's coming back as
black siren on the flash guys it's not
like she's going hey Katie still works
next door to me so I'm fine we're all
good we we just you know never easy it's
the hardest part of working on these
shows this is the progression that they
choose to go in um I think the hardest
thing for me it was more about
physicality than actually the acting
part of it but it was the scene where
Katie Cassidy's character walks in and
she's basically like Nyssa you need to
give up the serum to save Thea's life
and I'm like no this is how I go over
lines in my head blah blah blah no
seriously all of a sudden or maybe was
with Oliver I don't know somebody was
there and then all of a sudden the
league it was Malcolm basically he's
like tricking me into doing something
and then like my people are there and
then his people come running in and we
have this like fight scene but we were
in this warehouse which was really dark
and it was cold and every time we
breathed you could see our breath in the
air but they decided to wet down all of
the concrete they do this to you guys
conscious they soak the entire thing so
anytime anyone a member of the League of
Assassins came running in no matter what
side they were on
they skid to a stop and it took them our
stunt guys are so good that they kind of
figured out how to skid to a stuff like
where they need to start skidding but
the first three or four times they just
kept taking each other out
because I was supposed to fight this one
guy and he starts sliding and I'm like
oh oh he's not stopping he just like
took me out like a bowling pin I was
like whoa
and then the best part is Katie Cassidy
I love her so much but she she is like
one of the people that gives a hundred
and ten percent so if you're like give
more it is two hundred percent but she's
wearing 3-inch heels on wet concrete and
they're just like swing harder so we're
all watching behind the monitor and says
epic scene so she goes to swing and
Ulsan she's no longer than the frame she
just totally ate it and you just hear
this cackle of laughter as she's now on
the ground soaked because her feet went
out from underneath of her so that
entire day it was just people just
dropping like flies all over the place
and they're like but it looks really
good okay so that was that lady's
interment that is all we have time for
please give a massive report
you